I think one of the most important things
that we can have right now is a body of
journalists who reflect the diversity of
the country and in so doing you
implicitly get a reflection of the
diversity of the stories that happen in
this country but ira Lippmann Center is
an outgrowth of our benefactors idea
that journalism can be a critical
institution as it relates to shoring up
and defending civil and human rights the
fellowship program is really interesting
it brings journalists in from around the
country and helps to support work that
might not get done otherwise and so we
can be an institution that really helps
journalists cover stories that might be
missed in other contexts civil rights we
think of pretty straightforwardly as
those rights that are guaranteed to
people in the Constitution and human
rights we have thinking about the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
that comes about in the 1940s but we're
mostly driven by stories in which there
are people who may not have a great deal
of power whose rights are being violated
or threatened by individuals and
entities that have a great deal more
power than they do and we have a
workshop function where we will be
bringing in journalists from around the
country to convene with policy makers
elected officials activists people who
were in various human and civil rights
communities to kind of shape how these
issues become covered and so we think
that in those three arenas we can
actually make a difference